قد تكون مسؤولة بالفعل عن
إصابة واحدة من كل خمسة إصابات بفيروس كوفيد 19 في
الولايات المتحدة
، ويعتبر متغير دلتا حاليًا
أكبر تهديد في الولايات
المتحدة لمحاولتنا القضاء على 19.
تشير الأبحاث الجديدة إلى أن المتغير
ينتشر بسرعة أكبر في
المناطق التي يتم فيها تطعيم عدد أقل من الأمريكيين
و  يعتقد كبار مسؤولي الصحة في الولايات المتحدة
أنه سيكون البديل السائد
في الولايات المتحدة في الأشهر
إن لم يكن الأسابيع المقبلة ، هذا هو الأكثر
قابلية للانتقال من بين جميع المتغيرات التي
رأيناها ورأينا ما حدث في المملكة المتحدة حيث
تجاوز  أمة بأكملها ، لذلك أنا قلق من أن هذا
سيحدث في الولايات المتحدة
، حيث يجد نموذج حديث متغيرًا يشبه دلتا
يُفترض أنه
أكثر قابلية للانتقال بنسبة 60 في المائة من
متغير ألفا الذي تم تحديده لأول مرة في المملكة المتحدة إلى
جانب 75 في المائة من الأمريكيين المؤهلين الذين
يتلقون التطعيم.
يؤدي فيروس كورونا إلى الارتداد من
أدنى مستوياته في الصيف
ليسبب أكثر من 3000 حالة وفاة في الأسبوع
في نقاط مختلفة خلال فصلي الخريف والشتاء
بالتزامن مع البرد.  عودة درين إلى
المدرسة وما إذا كان ذلك يدفع الناس
إلى الداخل مرة أخرى ،
لكن المسؤولين يقولون إن لقاحات covid19
توفر الحماية ضد متغير دلتا
بسبب ذلك
يقول الدكتور أنتوني فوسي أنه من غير المحتمل
أن يكون هناك عودة
في زيادة حالات covet-19 التي شوهدت في
عام 2020
ولكن  يقول إنه يمكن أن تكون هناك
زيادات موضعية مع استمرار الصيف
في الأماكن التي تكون فيها معدلات التطعيم
أقل ،
فلدينا الأدوات ، لذلك دعونا
نستخدمها ونقضي على تفشي المرض من أجل الصحة الدقيقة.